- I am a freestyle rapper,
which you all entirely agree with.
You're like, yeah, no,
you're gonna freestyle.
We know Britain's main exports -
freestyle rap and baking shows.
Those are the two things
we do really well.
Freestyle rap is rap
that's made up on the spot.
It's not written. It's not
prepared. It's not rehearsed.
It requires you lovely people
to start thinking of words, topics,
or phrases you would
like to hear a rap about.
What would you guys like a rap about?
You said Gordon Ramsay?
Can you like lift your hat up?
I just wanna check you're not him.
It's the type of thing he would do.
He would come to a show,
and shout his own name out.
Gordon Ramsay. Gordon Ram-
For those of you that don't know,
he's a very angry British chef.
He says things that I cannot say
'cause there are children around
the edges of the audience.
Gordon Ramsay is our first suggestion.
If you are stood along
this freeway, passageway,
sidewalk, that's what you call it.
Yet in England, we call it pavement.
I apologize. I'm picking up the lingo.
If you're over here, what
would you like a rap about?
Pardon?
Paperclip? Thank you very much.
Yes, lovely paperclip, Gordon Ramsay.
The rest of you,
it's your fault that we've got paperclip
as the second rap topic.
You could have said anything.
That lady was like, "No, stationary."
Let's come to the back.
If you're at the back of the horseshoe,
what would you like a rap about?
I beg your pardon?
That was, I was like, that
is a very, very small voice.
What was it?
Fire! Yeah! Don't shout that
in a crowded environment, kid.
(crowd laughing)
Fire, paperclips, Gordon Ramsay.
Let's come.
Hey, people who weren't
invited but are here anyway.
I'm glad you're here.
Look at all these nerds.
You're the real people, right?
These are, this is my crowd.
So, wait, what were you about to shout?
Brexit!
Go away. Leave.
Security. Remove this person.
Brexit. What about Brexit?
Brexit is a multifaceted affair.
By which I mean, it's a massive balls up.
What?
No, no, no.
You can't shout in, and then be like,
I don't actually know
what I was talking about.
I'm sorry.
Someone can help you out.
Something specific about Brexit.
I love this pose, by the way.
This is my favorite pose.
It's like half rockstar,
half lady shaving her legs.
Who knows?
We'll just do Brexit.
That's fine. I like your hat.
Let's get our final suggestion.
This can come from
anywhere, but it has to.
Yes. What?
Oh, that wasn't a suggestion.
That was just someone strolling
past, getting confused.
Let's get one final suggestion.
It has to be the best one of them all.
What's it gonna be?
Toothpick? Toothpick. Lovely stuff.
Do you use toothpicks, sir?
No. Okay.
I'm so, I was a bit worried I'd say that,
and you would just show
me a mouth full of gums,
and I'd be like, that's tragic.
So, we got toothpick. We
got Brexit. We got fire.
We got paper clips. And,
we've got Gordon Ramsay.
And, we've got a perfectly
timed helicopter.
This then, lovely people of
Las Vegas slash New York,
who knows where we are.
This is a freestyle.
That's a wrap made up on the spot,
and it goes something like this.
Let's drop that beat.
To remind you, the suggestions -
paperclip, that's my favorite,
toothpick, Gordon Ramsay, fire.
And, what was our other one that we got?
Brexit. How could we forget?
Genuinely, I still have
flashbacks to that day,
so this is what we're gonna do.
A freestyle rap, and it's
not gonna be anywhere near
as atrociously bad as you're
expecting it to be. Cool.
♪ Hoping on the beat. ♪
♪ Yeah, respect it, check it, ♪
♪ like five years ago, we
will voting for Brexit. ♪
♪ People like pee you, we hate the EU. ♪
♪ They genuinely voted. ♪
♪ I can't believe they
do. Like 51 to 49%. ♪
♪ I was like, this ain't gonna end well. ♪
♪ Then, they presented
the whole way forward. ♪
♪ It was kind of hard. ♪
♪ A hard Brexit. ♪
♪ Oh my God. ♪
♪ I was really worried. ♪
♪ We had the fuel shortages. ♪
♪ If you watch the British
news, they reported this. ♪
♪ We had the man with
the crazy blonde hair. ♪
♪ Boris Johnson, if you're not aware, ♪
♪ but he was in there. ♪
♪ down in, down in street ♪
♪ right to the microphone. ♪
♪ He's like, blah, blah, blah. ♪
♪ What's this? When it's
a vote, I'm confused. ♪
♪ I've got no plan, weird blonde hair ♪
♪ like a more familiar man. ♪
♪ You see him over here. ♪
♪ And I understand, he gets
angry in the restaurant. ♪
♪ That's Gordon Ramsay ♪
♪ with his blonde locks,
sweaty red forehead. ♪
♪ He goes to the kitchen. ♪
♪ He starts to forage. ♪
♪ He's like this ain't great. ♪
♪ It's not a good time. ♪
♪ I looked inside your fridge. ♪
♪ It's just dripping with grime. ♪
♪ All the horrible rust.
All the horrible mold. ♪
♪ Need to throw your chef
right out into the cold. ♪
♪ I know that's not his accent. ♪
♪ I can't do it properly. ♪
♪ It's like when Americans
try to do Cockney. ♪
♪ It doesn't work. ♪
♪ You should stick to your own accent, ♪
♪ shouting out "Toothpick!" ♪
♪ What? Like something
for a little olive. ♪
♪ Yeah. You throw the devil horns. ♪
♪ Yeah. And I acknowledge. A toothpick? ♪
♪ Put it in your mouth,
and you arrive there. ♪
♪ You look like a Staten
island taxi driver. ♪
♪ When you're rocking
a long bit of wood, ♪
♪ you get a bit of meat in your molar. ♪
♪ It's understood. ♪
♪ Pretty good with the reach. ♪
♪ You can excavate the teeth,
and if there's no toothpick, ♪
♪ you can just seize the nearest
thing. There's so many - ♪
♪ long, cylindrical, and metal. ♪
♪ That's a piece of stationary,
and get it over there. ♪
♪ And, then, I let it slip ♪
♪ between my molars and my canines. ♪
♪ I use a paper clip. ♪
♪ No need for A4 or legal size. ♪
♪ Paperclips? Yeah. I'll
just put it inside. ♪
♪ And, if you want make
sure that it's sterilized, ♪
♪ then from your back pocket, ♪
♪ you can provide a little lighter. ♪
♪ Flip the Zippo or the Bic. ♪
♪ And, then, the flame comes
out, and that's how we spit. ♪
♪ I know my man is shouted over there. ♪
♪ Must admire in the crowded area. ♪
♪ He just screamed out fire! ♪
(rap beat continues)